[Music]
this morning our series pushing the
limits takes us to a school that's
empowering young people of color who
have sky-high ambitions the new
york-based red tail flight academy is
training black men and women for careers
in aviation the program is inspired by
tuskegee airmen the country's first
black military pilots michael george
spoke with several students clocking
flight hours as they prepare to become
commercial pilots
the freedom of soaring through the skies
that's been a dream for 21 year old trey
jackson his entire life ever since like
two years old i saw the movie top gun i
feel the need
for speed
seeing tom cruise in the f-14s
that was my whole entire motivation to
look into the world of aviation but
becoming a pilot wouldn't be easy
training alone can cost around a hundred
thousand dollars
then jackson got a call he never
expected he'd been chosen to join a
program looking for a new generation of
young black pilots i literally prayed
for something like exactly like this
program the program called red tail
flight academy is inspired by the
legendary tuskegee airmen pilots trained
the tuskegee way go on to earn high
praise the first black military pilots
who battled both nazis during world war
ii and racism back home
jackson and fellow aspiring pilot maya
coley are a part of the academy's first
class
what did it feel like when you heard you
were chosen when you were selected for
this program
i cried
it was unbelievable for me because
a lot of people who look like me they
don't know where to start or they don't
know how to start because it is such a
financial burden but 80 years after the
tuskegee airmen first took flight
aviators like jackson and coley are
still rare black aircraft pilots and
engineers make up less than four percent
of those employed in the industry i
think we're making a change glenn
frazier founder of red tail made it his
mission to diversify the skies there is
a problem with awareness within the
inner city in the urban areas to know
that this particular career
is a possibility the simulators are
really a critical component board member
ann palmer says the young pilots in
training now carry the legacy of the
tuskegee airmen a legacy started by
aviators like her father one of the
original airmen my father was second
lieutenant augustus l palmer an
extraordinary father but an
extraordinary man this is personal for
you very very there's nothing greater
than to see
what
your ancestors stood for
actually honored and perpetuated
what do you think your dad would say
seeing them take to the sky
straighten up fly right
get it done introduce another notch of
flaps jackson and coley are now living a
dream they once thought was out of their
reach it's always been that intimidation
of
for me black women can't fly or black
women won't be able to take on this
challenge
and that was motivation for me what does
it feel like now to take off
oh my gosh
honestly it's been like the most like
amazing experience oh sorry i'm teared
up that's all right yeah um
i was telling my family i wanted to be a
pilot and then actually finally being
able to and actually take off and
actually holding my pipe's license it
was a great experience
[Applause]
jackson now has more than 150 flight
hours you're about the same age as the
tuskegee airmen were when they flew do
you ever think about that think about
that all the time it's a lot of
motivation to wake up in the morning
jackson and coley both hope to become
commercial pilots when they graduate
this spring and they'll always remember
the shoulders they're standing on
trey what do you think the tuskegee
airmen would say about
you guys
i think that would definitely say that
we are following in their footsteps and
um
really trying to just push
the
just the bar even higher each and every
time
for cbs mornings michael george new
windsor new york
i love his passion for it that it drives
him to tears just thinking about what it
represents how far he's come and you
know really talk about standing on the
shoulders of ancestors yeah to be able
to do
and what that plan looked very little to
me that was the boy they started a
little bit he loved it they started the
little ones and then they did the big
ones yeah aviation is a possibility yeah
young black kids yeah that's awesome
great advertisement for flying just that
smile yes